you're in those shoes all day the
blisters the blisters oh it's a tough
life it's a really tough time to talk
life
what led you to be a costume designer
well i think i always
liked clothes and i was interested
and originally when i was a teenager i
wanted to be a fashion designer but that
kind of
went away and i became much more
interested in drama and costumes and
eventually went to nida and when i was
at nida the national institute of
dramatic art i really felt like i'd
found what i wanted to do
and my people and
what was going to be right for me and
i've loved doing it ever you know ever
since you can tell
just as well i haven't wasted my time
i think it's always important when you
approach costuming somebody you have to
take into account who they are
and their performance like you have to
work
with
the actor i remember you always saying
to me too that it's an interpretation i
remember that was something that really
resonated with me especially about the
costumes but also in terms of
performance because how are you ever
going to be
you're going to be
olivia priscilla and you're going to
bring humanity and insights about the
real person but priscilla is priscilla
and she's still thankfully here with us
and you know same with austin and elvis
there's only one elvis and that
unfortunately yeah it was such a joyful
thing i think coming into those fittings
and seeing those iconic images and then
the sort of pieces that you had put
together like your interpretation and
the development of that over time i
thought it was really really interesting
well i'm glad that you did and i thought
that it was great working with you
because you're very thoughtful you're
very smart
and it was a really good conversation
you wore the clothes instead of the
clothes wearing you which was great you
brought
so much to the costumes thank you and
that all comes down to creating a
performance and being an actor you do
what you can in costume design to be
a support to that process all this time
all these people have
done all this stuff but at the end of
the day it's really about the actor and
a piece of glass and trying to channel
all the work of all those departments in
a single moment the costume aspect of it
because it's so integral not only to the
story but also to priscilla the way that
she sort of presented herself to the
world was very important to have that so
taken care of and i remember like your
attention to detail olivia was so
patient because we just tried on so much
stuff but i think that's part of the
discovery process and also some of the
pleasure as well like i think being an
actor sounds like maybe a wanky thing to
say but it is about the entire breadth
of experience it's not just standing in
front of a camera and saying your lines
it's the costuming it's doing the whole
process to have the resource from
you know from prada prada and meumu
to actually be able to do that
particularly in a pandemic when it was
kind of hard to get remember the coat
that you guys whipped up in like two
days yes three days yes that was one of
the most astonishing things i think i've
witnessed was you guys putting together
this iconic coat in like three days
there are two iconic looks that
priscilla
um priscilla wears this sort of
patchwork leather coat
um very long almost full length and
elvis is wearing a tracksuit we decided
in discussion with baz and talking to
all of you that it would be great to
kind of
re-um quote that yeah there's a final
together scene in the movie and
it's a testament to the team oh my god i
know i just couldn't believe it me
neither two days two days fit me
perfectly i know and it was exactly the
cut it was all the shape exactly the
same it was crazy and they were teaching
themselves how to do crafts they've
never done before like all that
crocheting along the leather edges it
was insane and the loving work that the
team does like even with elvis's
tracksuit it was so immaculately
reproduced but also taking into account
austin
and
you know thinking about how big
he should be because
you know they're different physical
types
how do we exaggerate with the tracksuit
the team was truly incredible that was a
really good that was crazy yeah
from your perspective what is the role
of the costume designer i think
my job is to
help translate the director and the
actor's
vision for the character and kind of
help tell the story help in whatever i
way i can to support a performance
and also
to help the audience understand
who the person is it's a combination of
the historical context and the story so
the audience isn't going ah why are they
wearing that yeah i think clothes can be
a very integral vehicle for storytelling
particularly when we go over so much
time and they're still in the 50s the
60s and the 70s the progressiveness of
time and how that sort of manifests
physically as well is so important of
the cultural aspects too look at
priscilla a case in point she starts off
kind of this very 50s young girl
in
very
germany
isolated
and ends up being a woman taking control
of her life which is kind of the whole
history of that period for women
absolutely sexual liberation and women's
liberation with priscilla too i think
the aspect too of
the fact she changes once she realizes
that you know maybe the relationship is
sort of suffocating her more than it is
supporting her growth you can see that
reflected in the way that she dresses
you know when we compare the the double
decker hair and and that blue that
beautiful blue i don't know what you
would call that pantsuit um to what we
leave her with too it's such a
transgression i always think of you and
those denim flares as striding out into
the woods yes exactly it's the first
time you really see her in jeans when i
see you in those flares i think of that
stride like walking into the future
through that door
through the beautiful white light very
angelic going from those quite
restrictive clothes of the 50s to this
feeling of
female freedom i suppose yeah if you
have good costumes you should be able to
read more into it than just that person
is wearing a red shirt i agree you
should be able to feel who the person is
and where you are because people make
decisions every day about how they want
to present themselves to the world some
decisions are good some decisions not so
good but all decisions are interesting
i think the costumes transported me into
the world of priscilla presley in the
way that they i think you know we're in
2020 or in 2021 i think at the time or
2020 when we were shooting it sort of
eased stepping into a time place that
was very different to the present day
you know the attention to detail and
also how comfortable that i felt in the
clothes
really helped in
lessening the feeling of it feeling like
a costume and more of it feeling like it
was lived in which i think was one of
the most integral parts of this story
and how we were going to tell it was
that we wanted it to feel lived in and
less like a costume yeah i always think
of costumes as clothes you know yeah
yeah i don't felt like by the end they
felt like clothes clothes that i had
worn hundreds of times over you wanna
walk onto every set feeling confident i
think that's how you deliver your best
performance is when you feel safe
confident taken care of and a lot of
that starts with costuming because it's
what you're wearing it's what you're
representing it's an extension of
yourself regardless of what you're
playing or who you're playing or when
you're playing it one of my aims is to
make sure that the act is comfortable
because it's completely pointless
sending someone on set in who doesn't
feel good or who is like unsure it's a
waste of everyone's time i also really
appreciated that with you because you
did always ask you're always like how do
you feel what do you prefer do you like
this or like there was a conversation
there which sometimes doesn't always
happen i really feel like if you don't
feel comfortable or don't like it for
what other reason it could be a comfort
factor because you have to climb mount
everest and we've put you in stilettos
or whatever it could be a self-conscious
factor yeah you might think i have i
don't like my i look forward to
it or i don't yeah yeah right
fundamentally it is about supporting the
actor because if the actor is not
feeling
good or
kind of self-conscious and confident
that fits in with what they're trying to
do exactly choices
it doesn't mean that you always have to
be dressed
like
you know looking like you're at a
premiere no no but it's just that it
really fits i know shoes are really
important to actors and if shoes are
uncomfortable
so many switches do you remember
absolutely just saying before in that
last scene the breakup scene i
originally had heels on and i was
running and i couldn't i kept slipping
and we had to switch them over you've
got to deal with the practicalities you
got to deal with a comfort factor
because what people don't understand is
an actor isn't just doing the scene
once
you're in those shoes all day the
blisters the blisters well it's a tough
life it's a really tough top life
well you made it look easy
[Music]